South Koreans are not
having enough babies,
which is a big problem for the military.
Look at this wild chart.
This is how many babies
South Koreans are having.
And you can see that
it dips below this line,
which means South Koreans
are having less than one child per woman.
This is a big crisis
for the South Korean military,
because South Koreans are required
to serve in their military.
But in the next 50 years,
the number of people able to serve
is going to be cut in half.
Meanwhile, the nuclear-armed neighbor to
the north
has one of the largest armies
in the world.
So one group of South
Koreans came up with a solution:
The Senior Army.
500 seniors like average age 63,
have formed a volunteer group
to train for military action.
They’re not affiliated with the official army, but
their goal is to be prepared to fight
in case there is a conflict.
So as South Korea's population dwindles
because of this low birth rate,
senior might be the solution to the army.
If you want to better understand
global politics, follow along for more.